[Music]
the life-changing coronavirus pandemic
is making a lot of people think about
changing their working lives in one
survey by the pew research center
about two-thirds of unemployed adults
say they've considered making a career
change
one such person is christian simone of
minneapolis
she reinvented her career after she was
laid off
it was definitely a shocker
but in the same breath it was a blessing
in disguise as well when christian
simone
was laid off in december at her job as a
corporate project manager
she had an awakening it really just put
a hard focus on
me looking in the mirror and saying are
you really living
or are you just existing coping with
unemployment
the pandemic and the george floyd
protests in her city
she knew it was time for a change i
applied to grad school to get my
master's in social work
i want to go for my goals of becoming a
therapist focus on black women and women
of color
while saving for grad school christian
is also using
extra time at home to work on her beauty
and wellness
youtube channel skincare beauty
is a form of meditation i really wanted
to
just have something beautiful in a very
dark time
spring fashion 2020 has exited the chat
and be a constant reminder that you
deserve beauty as well
losing her job has meant a strict budget
and
relying on unemployment checks but
christian
is eager for her fresh start when i went
to work
i focused on the fact that you got to
pay your bills so you got to do what you
have to do
but to actually show up as myself my
authentic self
is the most liberating
yeah that's such a profound question are
you really living or are you just
existing a lot of folks have asked
themselves that in the last year so
cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger joins us jill good morning
if someone is thinking about a career
change
where do they start well of course
use christian's advice which is you got
to pay your bills but beyond that
you really want to start researching
what your career is going to be looking
like in the future so
is it your industry is it another
industry and do that work and spend the
time
next well you really got to dust off the
old resume and the cover letters
yes we still use them they still are the
point of entry
don't forget that you've got to actually
practice those zooms it's different
being on a zoom in your existing
workplace than with new people
and of course be careful about your
social profiles because
those are going to be examined by any
future
employers so be careful there which part
of the job market's actually growing
right now
jill well as you would imagine
technology and e-commerce just exploded
i think
every day we hear about new warehouse
opportunities but there are some in
upper level management as well
you also want to look at healthcare
because telemedicine is going to become
massive online learning a really
interesting
area it's really growing and of course
close to our hearts digital
entertainment
many companies looking to beef up their
streaming services and the people who
can
help them get there a lot of people like
christian jill as you know
figured out a way to get a side hustle
that gives you some some income
so when do you know to make the decision
from letting the side
making the side hustle your full-time
job you know we've always heard these
funny stories about someone says oh i'm
a cook
i want to open a b don't do that okay do
exactly what christian is doing which is
you practice what that hobby that
avocation is you see if you can make
money
and you can slowly make the transition
when you can afford to do so
interesting fact here in the first year
of the pandemic so going back to last
february
through the next 12 months we saw 4.4
million
new businesses be created that's a 41
increase from the previous year now some
of this is necessity
but a lot of people are saying you know
what i want to be my own boss
and i can actually do it or they've all
they've said to themselves
i've always wanted to do i've always
wanted to be and now is a good time to
do something like that
right jill if you're really serious
about becoming self-employed what are
the benefits that you need to make sure
that you have this is a
critical question so uh thanks to the
new anchor for
joining in on this one the health
health insurance is obviously the most
important thing now the affordable care
act
has an open enrollment period right now
through
the middle of august you may if you were
laid off be entitled to cobra
from the government through september so
those health insurance plans
extremely important how about a
retirement plan maybe you had a nice
401k
through your employer you don't have
that anymore you can open an ira
a roth ira as your business builds a sep
ira
and many people have life and disability
insurance through their workplace
you may want to check before you make
the move whether you can pull that into
your
next career it's called portability you
want to see if you can take your
coverage
pay for it yourself it may be cheaper
than going out and replacing that
coverage
in your next iteration salary very
important jill how do you go about
negotiating a salary in a new industry
i feel like we need lisa demour here to
help us
first of all you really want to do again
let's go back to the research the
research is important because you want
to know what is this
paying in for for my position and you
want to compare
apples to apples right if you are making
50
000 in one job you're moving to a new
industry you might have to take a step
back
so you find out the salary range now you
then say
in the interview you say so what's the
range for this position gail king that
you're hiring for
and you give me the range and you say oh
it's a forty to fifty thousand and you
say
great i say the end of that
at the high end of that range at 50 so
you do say go for the highest
you do say go for the high end not in
the middle okay okay
yeah because behaviorally what the
employer is going to do is anchor
that number meaning that's the number
they're going to think they have to pay
you to gain
all right thank you jill schlesinger we
appreciate it we'll be right back stay
with us